but first welcome to the end of day 10
can you believe it or a national shut
down because of a virus that arrived
here via China now we have a lot of new
information for you at this hour the
number of coronavirus infections in the
US now stands at more than 83,000 that's
an increase of about 20,000 from
yesterday we're doing a lot more testing
the day before the number jumped by
eleven thousand seven hundred the number
of those recovered is 1864 and the
number of those deaths is at least now
those who have died at least twelve
hundred and one an increase of 314 from
the previous 24-hour period of the day
before that death rose by two hundred
two hundred twelve so we're not at peak
at least not yet and certainly not in
the nation's kovat hot spots now New
York doesn't surprise you probably
remains the epicenter of this virus with
55% of all new infections and one-third
of all deaths occurring there Governor
Cuomo offered some good news on the
issue that people were understandably
freaking out about just a few days ago
that's the question of the availability
of gowns and masks equipment and PPE is
an ongoing issue right now we do have
enough PPE for the immediate future the
New York City hospital system confirmed
that so we have enough in stock now for
the immediate need but he offered
another stark warning on ICU beds and
ventilator needs ventilators ventilators
ventilators we're still shopping for
ventilators all across the country we
need more hospitals have a fifty thirty
thousand bed capacity we're trying to
get to one hundred and forty thousand
bed capacity between the hospitals and
the overflow facilities we're also
scouting dorms scouting hotels for
emergency beds nowadays ago the angle
had started to crunch the real numbers
from both Italy's kovat experience in
China's and the dire warnings that
hundreds of thousands of ventilators
were gonna be needed and potentially
millions of Americans that's what they
were saying could die neither of which
matched the new data that we were
looking at now these projections were
based on a model done by the team at the
Imperial College in London well today
this is what our instinct was the lead
researcher did an about-face on those
terrifying projection projections the
very projections that drove so much of
our response that was the report that
said there would be 500 thousand deaths
in the UK and 2.2 million deaths in the
United States they've adjusted that
number in the UK to 20 thousand the
predictions of the models don't match
the reality on the ground in either
China South Korea or Italy when people
start talking about 20% of a population
getting infected it's very scary but we
don't have data that matches that based
on the experience and that data of
actual kovat hospitalizations and ICU
needs informs the question of how many
ventilators will be needed and the
nightmare scenario floated that would
have to then ration care right now you
can see the state these cases are
concentrated in highly urban areas there
are other parts of the states that have
lots of ventilators in other parts of
New York states that don't have any
infections right now so we can be
creative we can meet the need by being
responsive but there's no model right
now I mean no reality on the ground
where we can see that 60 to 70 percent
of Americans are going to get infected
in the next 8 to 12 weeks now it appears
that Governor Cuomo's dire projections
are also based on that original faulty
model that didn't include the clinical
reporting by the Chinese and healthcare
in Italian healthcare professionals now
as viewers of this show you were already
aware of the faulty modeling done on
Kovan because I asked doctor foul Qi
about this on Tuesday night if the
numbers are not right then maybe that
affects the decision-making
about when the country can gradually get
back to business you're absolutely right
Lauren well on both the issue of
promising therapies like
hydroxychloroquine and on the analysis
used for these doomsday predictions the
Ingram angle has been days if not weeks
ahead of some of the major news networks
frankly all of them now why is that how
is that because I was lucky enough to
assemble my own team of medical advisors
and you all know who you are out there
and they were raising all the right
questions stuff that I wouldn't know
about but they do and they actually are
people who treat kovat patients day in
and day out many of the so-called
experts I was thinking about this today
have failed us in the past on really key
issues think about Iraq think about
trade with China think about the
importance of border enforcement the
internet bubble the housing bubble and
now the CDC's kovat testing time will
tell just how accurate or inaccurate the
experts were in this crisis was the
total shutdown the right way to go or
should we have taken a more modified
approach more akin to what Sweden is
doing should be waiting should we be
waiting for this thing called herd
immunity to develop or just force
everyone to isolate and hope the second
wave of infections never comes in the
meantime we're lucky to have a president
who trusts but then verifies what the
experts are saying and then he balances
it with the overall needs of the
American people in the American economy
he announced today that he'll be
releasing new guidelines to the
governor's for a gradual relaxing of the
shutdown in the areas that have managed
to escape the worst of the virus we do
have 19 out of our 50 states to be
reminded that had early cases but have
persistently low level of cases and at
this point have less than 200 cases so
that's almost 40 percent of the country
with extraordinarily low numbers and
they are testing these 19 states are
doing still active containment there at
200 cases despite the fact that they've
been measuring
over the last three to four weeks but
even then if those Area C restrictions
lifted soon it doesn't mean that people
should just go about their merry way
like before the virus that's not what
the president I think is going to advise
they should not still let their guards
down
I want those guidelines to go even when
we're open and fully operational and
frankly much of the guidelines like
shaking hands maybe people aren't gonna
be shaky and handset even when we're
open as soon as we open that doesn't
mean you're gonna stop with the
guidelines you'll still try and distance
yourself maybe not to the same extent
because you have to lead a life but I
think the time is coming Oh common sense
when will that reign supreme again well
he understands that the virus or no
virus if people don't have a way to make
a living on the other side of this if
things collapse businesses go out
bankruptcies restaurants go under jobs
never return certain types of jobs don't
return well the long term damage to
America will dwarf what this hideous
virus has already done to us and those
are my thoughts at the end of America's
shutdown day 10